[Music]
so i'm a pilot i told you that already
um if i was going to choose an emblem to
that exemplifies the wonder the majesty
the the hopefulness of the four forces
of flight
that allow a plane to stay aloft i would
not
choose a tenuous tendril of an aircraft
such as a paper airplane i would choose
the a-10 warthog it's ugly it's it's
huge
it's bulky it carries tons of weapons
and it likes to get down and dirty why'd
you choose a paper airplane
got it that's a great question so so my
logo is a
is a gold paper airplane and i did it
because that to me represents
entrepreneurship so
we want entrepreneurs we want to go
further we want to
get out of where we are now we want to
build something we want to explore we
want to
we want to fly that's what we want to do
but
we don't have money you know at the
beginning nobody's got money
you don't have the resources you
probably don't have the connections i
mean if you do bless you but most people
you're starting up with nothing and you
didn't go to school for it and
you know so you but you've got the
tenacity you've got the will you've got
the hard work you've got the drive so to
me that's a paper airplane
it's not a jet or it's not your favorite
airplane like that costs a lot how much
does your
your thing cost you can't buy the uh a10
warthog
yeah but it's military but yeah if you
wanted to 20 million
20 million yeah perfect great like
nobody's got 20 million dollars to start
a business
but you got a piece of paper so start
and i love the idea of like we're
battling the elements and our edges are
getting torn and tattered and bruised
but we still fly the airplane
flies across the screen and then you
hear the sonic boom of it breaking a
sound barrier
and and for a paper airplane to do that
i think that's what entrepreneurs do
every day
i think people should try
entrepreneurship i think people should
try youtube
i think people should try to write i
think people should try
to be a good student like i think you
should try these things and then see
what you gravitate towards whether you
don't even have to be good at it it's
just do you like it
because if you like writing but you suck
at it and you're making spelling
mistakes and all of this stuff
and you might have people around you
telling you that you'll never be a
writer but if you just
like it and you keep doing it
you'll get great at it you met someone
and he said something like you're the
only person who ever believed in me you
evan carmichael
and you never met this guy so what is it
about belief that is so
empowering to the person who is believed
in
i think it's the world's biggest problem
i think i think everybody i start with
the premise that everybody's got
michael jordan level genius at something
like you're the best in the world at
something
but you don't you don't believe that you
are we're not actually afraid of failing
we're afraid of failing in front of
people we're afraid of failing and who
sees us
we'll sing in the shower but we won't
sing on the street corner that's why i
think belief is at the core
when you believe in the ability to go
off and create something the one thing
that you do
doesn't work but the next thing and the
next thing the next thing the belief
that it's possible or the hope
that you could be in a better spot than
you are right now
without that belief that you can change
your life
you don't change your life despite all
the evidence being
otherwise there's lots of people who
came from where you're at with less than
what you've got
and they went off and crushed it and
you're not because of the story you told
yourself
not just because of the evidence so i
think it's both it's not just like black
and white
evidence that's it um we make emotional
decisions and so you have to
tap into those emotions to serve you
instead of hold you back
if you're worried if your heart's
beating if you've got an idea
to write a book to start a show to
interview somebody to
whatever and your heart's beating i
think that means it's go time where
we've been trained to say
let's play small let's not do it let's
back down that's too scary
are you proud of the effort that you put
in today because if you're constantly
proud of the effort
the results will happen they will come
if you're putting in your max effort
you may not be happy with the result for
the day
if you have a a writing count for your
book and you want to get a
500 words done today you might write 500
words that are crap and not be happy
with it the result
isn't there but you did the 500 words
and i i pat myself on the back for doing
the 500 words
and hopefully that leads to like if i
did that every day not every day is
going to be great
but i will ultimately create great
[Music]
things